thank you so can everyone hear me we're
good they gave me a laser pointer which
is a terrible idea but I can't point
that high otherwise so I've tweeted a
link to the slides my Twitter handrails
Calla had if you want to follow along if
you want to experiment instead of
listening to me feel free to go there
there's all sorts of information other
demos to look at other resources check
that out spoiler alright so I'm not
talked about the new mobile web because
we tried that once we tried an old
mobile web we had whap we had wml who
here remembers like Nokia feature phones
with wet ok hey I guess you come close
to to where Nokia is from and you get
people who remember that that's great um
the the power of the web and the reason
whap failed and the reason the iphone
and things like that I've succeeded is
that the web is one platform there's
only one web it's open its universal
it's decentralized the same web is on my
phone that is on my laptop there's no
single gatekeeper there's no web store
that I have to go to and convince
someone to let me publish on the web
there are many new domain providers mini
hosting providers have many options and
this is the power of the web as a medium
it's a very very low barrier to entry
very low friction Democratic medium and
I think that's important so I work for
Mozilla and Mozilla works for the web
Mozilla's a nonprofit that in its
manifesto states that the Internet is a
global public resource that must remain
open and accessible and a key to that is
ensuring that there's a balance between
private interest on the web and public
interest on the web the way that we work
to ensure that balance is about building
firefox firefox is a completely free
open-source web browser you can hack on
the code we're rewriting our dev tools
and react so if you know react you can
make a huge contribution come talk to me
later if you want to learn how to get
involved but we build Firefox so that
when the world's largest corporations
meet to determine what is going into the
web platform what the web is going to
look like that we have earned a place at
that table as a pea
and as a fellow implementer of the web
and that we can influence that we can
speak for the public good as someone
that doesn't have a profit motive I
think that's really important i think
the web is is a global resource it's a
public resource it needs to be preserved
feel free to talk to me about that
afterwards so part of the power of the
web is its ubiquity this is the internet
of [ __ ] twitter account talking about
all the failures in the iot field and
it's being displayed on a samsung smart
fridge in a showroom at a home appliance
store the power of this is that that's
mobile.twitter.com on that smart fridge
samsung didn't have to go out to twitter
and say hey will you please implement
twitter for fridge OS 10 and then they
didn't have another company say LG or
someone else coming and say ah but we
have a better fridge OS can you
implement for hours no they just
implement the web and they have access
to all the contents of the web has and
so the web has this this ability to
shape itself into new forms that we
hadn't imagined yet but all that content
is there it's hugely powerful if you
look closely there a couple things you
can you can learn about this this fridge
for one it's not using it's using the
Samsung built-in browser it's not using
Chrome or Firefox that's custom UI if
you scroll down further you can actually
see it's running Android but you also
know that it has a web connection inside
the showroom floor which means if you
buy the floor model depth of that fridge
you probably get access to home depot or
Sears Wi-Fi network so that's a pretty
good deal and we know that because if it
didn't have a web connection and we
tried to load mobile.twitter.com we'd
see something like this the connection
appears to be offline try again so the
web is ubiquitous but the web isn't
resilient the Twitter app will never do
this you never open twitter on your foam
and you're on a train or on a flight and
say oh I'm sorry just twitter isn't
available right now no you see what data
it had the last time it was available
and you can still compose tweets it'll
just say hey I can't send this until I'm
back online or I can't retrieve new
tweets until I'm back online so apps
have had this this user experience and
reliability
win over the web this talk is going to
talk about how to fix that before we go
on I'm going to be showing a fair amount
of code that uses some es6 features in
particular arrow functions you can think
of them as just a shorthand if you look
for that fat arrow there on the left
hand side are the parameters on the
right hand side is the return value so
these two lines are equivalent take X
return x times two there are some
nuances about how error functions are
different from normal functions but this
is a j/s conference you can ask anyone
else at your table and someone will know
the second thing you're going to see a
lot of our promises the signifier of
promises are this dot then method
promises are an official es6 codified
way of handling a synchronicity in
JavaScript we used to have to nest call
back inside call back inside call back
inside callback which worked but admit
that the order of execution of our code
wasn't a syntactic thing it wasn't this
statement than this statement this since
then this statement it was a side effect
of the nesting of our code makes a code
harder to reason about makes things
harder air is hard to deal with promises
let you just say do this dot then
whenever that finishes call this
callback then call this callback and if
any of them fail pass the error to this
handler you'll see this a lot fetch also
if you haven't seen it promisee
replacement for xml httprequest that's
valid syntax you say fetched you give it
a URL you can optionally pass like
method post I cannot I'm a professional
software developer I cannot write an xhr
request by hand thus intact can anyone
in the room do you remember the syntax
well enough all right you turn to
someone at your table improve it
fetch on the other game fetch data you
get a promise back the promise
eventually returns the data promises are
everywhere now that we have a way to
handle a synchronicity you'll see them
coming up in standards like fetch
service workers push background sync the
new es 2017 a sink and wait keywords are
just syntactic sugar around promises so
you'll have to understand how these work
I really recommend investing the time to
to go through some blog articles go
through some experiments figure these
things out so back on track reliability
how does service workers help us solve
reliability what's the service worker
showing hands who here knows what a
service worker is all right who here has
used them in production oh okay so maybe
if you can write an xhr by handed UV
service workers in production I believe
you on both of those counts there are
people doing this it's it's available
it's in the release versions of Firefox
and Chrome and opera basically service
workers are like script tags but for a
whole domain instead of for an
individual page so when you open a new
tab the scripts on the page run you
close the tab the scripts die service
workers aren't quite like that service
workers could be running without any
tabs open at all or you could have 10
tabs open all sharing the same service
worker so it's a way to start providing
an alternative to the page model of the
web not a replacement for an alternative
because there are some things in the
page model just doesn't work for of
course service workers are going to have
some some superpowers if they can run
without any tabs open and if they're
going to be able to do things like
making the web work offline so like any
other powerful API service workers
require a secure connection you have to
have a TLS certificate show hands let's
encrypt if people heard of used it okay
for those of you I haven't let's encrypt
as a joint venture between the
Electronic Frontier Foundation and
Mozilla to provide free TLS certificates
that are trusted by every browser that
are usable for anything private use
personal use corporate use for profit
whatever security should it shouldn't be
a choice between security and your
wallet so that's super great this tip if
you remember nothing else is worth at
least
two thousand kronor which to put it in
even further local terms is about for
pizza and a coke so so you could either
have a certificate or you could have a
certificate and some pizza I know what I
choose so how do these work you use a
script tag to do can I have per page
JavaScript for a service worker you have
to install the service worker file using
javascript so somewhere in a script tag
you check for support so you do feature
detection if service worker and
navigator then navigate our service
worker register and you pass it the
script to your JavaScript or the path to
your javascript file you can also set
the scope of the service worker by
default it would just be the folder that
the worker itself is N and this kind of
says what what page is my URL bar say
and what service worker gets to control
that page so by setting the scope to the
root any page on my domain could
potentially be controlled by this
service worker you can have multiple
service workers for your domain only one
will work at a time and the most
specific one is the one that's selected
one of the most immediate things you
might want to do is preload a cache we
want to make the web work offline there
are things you're going to want to have
available you're going to want your
stylesheet you're going to want your
basic a pelagic a service worker because
it's running in a separate thread it's
running independent of tabs every API
uses is event-based an asynchronous so
when we do this install step the
serviceworker file we downloaded saved
in the browser and it'll start running
the browser will then give it an install
event so we can add an event listener
for install and say alright don't
resolve this init like wait until we
open a cache and then add all these URLs
to the cash the caches API you say
caches that open and give it a name of a
cash if it doesn't exist it gets created
and then you get a cash reference to
that opened cash and you can do things
like add requests go and synthesize
requests delete things you can inspect
the whole cache the only things that
ever appear in this cache are things
that you put there it's subject to a
normal browser quotas like you would see
for index TV or other things if the
browser ever needs more space it'll stop
it will start
dropping from the least recently used
cash entire caches at once so you'll
never have a situation where like half
of your cash is missing either
everything you put in there is there or
nothing is there so I say all right on
the install event go and cash these
things for us they can be on other
domains they could be other resources
but we can say we want these files in
the cache and then the service worker
and this oh it's actually may be legible
a screen is huge if you're looking at
the slides yourself this is much more
legible but more important thing is just
these these graphics the serviceworker
can act as a proxy inside the users
browser that can intercept and modify
requests it can intercept and modify
responses so when a page goes and
request something like a style sheet
instead of going directly to the
Internet first a fetch event will happen
inside the serviceworker the
serviceworker could say all right well I
have that my cash I can respond from the
cache and that request will never
actually hit the network and it codes
pretty straightforward you can say all
right add an event listener for fetch
and then event respond with caches match
so caches match will search every cash
in that domain look for that events
request so that request object has the
URL the mode the method the headers and
then if we get a response back if the
response is truth if we had a cache hit
return from the cash otherwise go and
fetch out to the network just resend
that request it looks a little bit like
this started a page page once a file it
goes to the serviceworker service worker
says wait I'm going to check my cash if
that fails I'll go to the network and
I'll return that to the browser you can
also flip this and say actually I want
to try to go to the network first but if
that fails show the cash version so you
you're preferring the up-to-date version
and falling back to the cash you could
even build a hybrid that says I want to
try I want to immediately return the
cash version but in parallel I want to
go to the network and get an updated
version for the next time
as an example I've got a video here of
something happening on phone but there's
only one web so we're going to do it on
my desktop my normal browser instead
this is pokedex org which I previously
didn't understand anything about but
then Pokemon go happened and I can tell
you all about it so no one loss in the
author of pouch DB you wrote this as a
demo to show all sorts of techniques for
making sites work well offline one of
the things you'll notice is that in the
inspector all of the style sheets using
CSS spriting but it's just a normal link
rel stylesheet tag and it's a normal
script source j s main DJ s from the
perspective of this website it has no
idea that there's going to be a
serviceworker between it and the
internet it has no idea it's behind a
proxy but if i turn my Wi-Fi off what's
the network tab that's you know this
isn't surprising javascript can do this
but what if i refresh the page but still
worked if you look over the transferred
we can see that this is coming from a
serviceworker instead of the network and
we can actually go into any of these and
see the response headers we can see the
actual response this looks to the
browser just like a normal network
requests all the headers are there the
body is there it went out and just
instead of making it all the way to the
internet before it realized it didn't
have a network connection the
serviceworker stuff didn't said wait I
have that my cash I'm going to return
that in Firefox you can also go into the
storage panel look into cash storage and
see all of the files that are actually
cached by the site you also go into
index DB and see all the the pokemon
data is stored in there this whole site
is open source if you click on the about
link you get that super great resource
to look at and learn if we actually go
into the the worker another broke i'm
using a nightly build with some weird
settings so i'll go into about debugging
in firefox which will list all the
workers and so i can start this worker
up i can debug it
and then in here all right it's all
Babel if I'd whatever if we go into the
repo will do this later or you can do
this later on your own you'll see that
the code that Nolan's using literally is
these seven lines six lines we're saying
look in the cache if there's a response
return it otherwise go to the network so
you can do this for real and it it makes
a website that you know I can close it I
can open it again pokedex org just as if
I was online I'm not if I was in a
browser that didn't support service
workers like Safari and I try to go a
pokedex torg not connected to the
Internet so this is an interesting
property of service workers the first
time you hit the site you don't have the
serviceworker either even if your
browser supports it so your site always
has to work as if service workers
weren't there but if they are you get a
better experience when you come back and
when Apple finally decides to support
service workers so far our users will
also get a better experience without you
having to change any code the the nice
thing about service workers is that it
falls back to a traditional Internet
experience instead of being something
that locks people out you're not
splitting the web into the serviceworker
people and the people that don't let's
turn Wi-Fi back on service workers also
give you complete programmatic control
over requests and responses you don't
just have to do simple caching there's a
link in the slides to this project SW
delta which will intercept requests and
append the version you have so if you
ask for URL main DJ s and the version
your cash is one dot one dot one this
will attend a query parameter cash one
that one not one and then it has a
server-side implementation it looks at
the difference between the latest
version and the cash version creates a
diff ships the diff back the service
worker applies the diff to the the
cached version puts that back in the
cache and then returns that and so this
is a way to kind of ship deltas and save
a lot of band let's save a lot of time
for questionable increases are
non-trivial increases in complexity but
it gives you an idea of the sorts of
creative uses you could use this for
it's not just
or this file as it is unmodified the
second big gap with web versus apps is
engagement throughout the rest of the
conference think about how many times
you take your phone out turn on the
screen just glance at what notifications
are there or how many times you pull
your phone out of your pocket because it
vibrated to tell you you how to
notification apps can tell you when
they're done with something you don't
have to go in and check I don't have to
go and see has dr finished uploading
this file by switching the tab or
refreshing it it'll tell me when it's
done and the web has had the ability to
provide notifications and they can show
up just like any other native
notification but they've been limited to
being on a single page as long as you
have the page open it can give you a
desktop notification slack does this
service workers get you away from that
page model they give you a script that
can run independent of the tabs so you
could actually have a service worker
that when it got an event show in a
notification even if the tab wasn't open
so you can close your gmail tab and
still get notifications of new mail in
fact Facebook is doing this in
production these are notifications
native notifications on Android coming
from facebook com without the browser
being open at all again service workers
are vented so we'll use the push event
for this when we get a push event we say
okay show notification with a title and
a body done so we've looked at three
events so far and service workers
install which is when you first get the
serviceworker fetch which is when a
network request goes out trigger by an
image tag or a script tag or an xhr push
which is when the site wants to notify
the browser somehow there are many other
events that exist or will be coming a
background sync is one that says wake up
the service worker and let it do some
work when I come back online there are
proposals and ideas for things like
geofencing wake up the service worker
and let it run a call back when I enter
a geographic area or wake it up at this
time and date the service worker story
is much more generic and much more
general a general purpose than the
specific application
of make it offline suggests so where
does this push up and come from well
first when you push it'll look like a
completely neat browser native OS native
notification right inside it you can
disable notifications because that can
be annoying of course you have to give
permission the way you get permission is
in your JavaScript on your page you say
navigator serviceworker ready then once
the serviceworker is ready you can call
push manager subscribe and then if the
user clicks ok you get a subscription
object that subscription object has all
the metadata you need to show
notifications on your users computers so
what you'll want to do is you want to
take that subscription object turn into
JSON post it to your back-end somewhere
and save it have a database row that
says this user account has this
subscription metadata Mozilla has a
website called the serviceworker
cookbook at the ever so klever service
work ers domain that has annotated
examples of all of this for the push
example what you'll see is when you get
that subscription back inside is this
enormously ridiculous URL at updates top
pushed at services mozilla com and if
you post to that URL and if the Wi-Fi
works there we go hello world I get a
notification you see that the domain
returned in 201 created which lets me
know that that message was successfully
in queued for delivery to the browser do
it again and because these are native
operating system messages they show up
in my notification drawer and dismiss
them and mass what the heck is happening
here where did this URL come from I
learned graph is about an hour ago and
built a graph for us instead of a
whiteboard what happens is the website
does that get
request it says I want to be able to
show you service show you notifications
the browser asks the user the user can
sense the browser will go up to a third
party service operated by your browser
manufacturer so chrome ones what chrome
run runs one of these Mozilla runs one
of these I'll say hey I need a URL that
I can give to a site to notify me that's
number two you for service will generate
a random URL set it back to the browser
the browser will generate some
cryptographic keys client-side and pass
the URL and the crypto keys in step 4
back to the website that's where this
massive string comes from that's in the
the subscription object then when the
website wants to communicate with the
browser does it through this push
service so it sends a message to that
service and that service access message
queue because your laptop may be turned
off your phone maybe an airplane mode
you'll notice that i sent the header TTL
60 this says that I want this to be
queued for a maximum of 60 seconds
before it expires so if user comes
online in the next 60 seconds deliver
the message otherwise drop it of course
this is all open source you want to see
how this works our implementation is out
there the benefit to this architecture
is it gives you a persistent location to
queue messages compared to you trying to
talk to the browser directly and it
saves battery life because the browser
can have a single WebSocket connected to
this one service instead of an arbitrary
number so for instance on Android
Firefox for Android actually uses the
push service will go and use Google
Cloud messaging because an android phone
will always have a connection to that
service so we kind of proxy to that
again everything in here is encrypted we
don't want access we don't want to
anything about what metadata or what
messages you're sending we don't want
have that responsibility we don't want
to have that potential for privacy
invasion so without any message body all
this does is just wake up the push event
and say hey I've got something if you
want to send a message by you have to
encrypt it to the keys that the browser
passes to you at the same time it sends
the URL if we take this example again we
go back into about debugging so you can
see that all the service work
are asleep right now because they wake
up they handle their event they go back
to sleep that's all you had those event
wait and tell and event respond with
functions or methods they say like wait
until this is done until you turn the
service worker off like I'm not done yet
so I start this up and I hit debug we
see the push of nth listener show
notification let's go ahead and set a
breakpoint there I come over here thing
whoops sorry that's a different instance
alright so I got the break point there
let's say I'm offline so normally if i
want to receive these push events i
would need to be connected to that
service but now that i'm offline i don't
have that connection inside about
debugging I've got this push button
which will actually synthesize a push
event client side so I can hit this wow
why isn't the debugger working so this
is what happens when you run a nightly
build this literally worked last week
but we have been splitting Firefox into
multiple processes and that sometimes
causes issues I will file a bug about
that once we're gone and I will tweet
the link you can all follow it and be
like this messed up dan on stage please
fix faster yeah oh wait no I'm an idiot
hang on check this out that's the
breakpoint inside the body because the
functions are even registered right or
the listeners always been already been
registered so if i run this now bing it
works another thing that's messing up on
stage is apple will turn on do not
disturb mode when you connect to a
projector so i've been sitting there
like why aren't there any notifications
and they're all just piling up in the
background alright so we've got this
event we look at it we can see it's a
push on it we can pop this open you know
see there's no data associate with it
whatever it's a debugger you can step
through it play with that on your own
the last thing at manifests these are
how we solve installation what do I mean
by that
when we think about apps native apps you
can install them you can put them on
your home screen you can rearrange them
give them a place of prominence on your
device if I'm going to be using the bus
schedule a lot if I'm going to be using
the weather website a lot I want to have
one tap access to that the web has
historically either you have bookmarks
which like gets super ugly 16 by 16
images scaled up to be the size of
whatever the launcher needs to be or you
have to go into your browser then into
the bookmark menu then go past all the
things you swear you were going to read
later and dig out the the thing you
wanted it'd be way nicer if we get add
stuff to the home screen that's what
manifests do you manifest act kind of
like head tags they provide metadata but
for multi-page contexts like web apps or
larger sites this is the production
manifester most of it for flipkart which
is an indian e-commerce retailer in the
head of their document they'll say link
rel manifest and point to this JSON file
then they can provide a name a short
name icons with various sizes and types
they can set the start URL to say the
experience for the site begins on this
page even if you're on some other page
later and you want to to interact with
this as an app it knows that that's the
home that's the initial starting
location you can launch our lock the
orientation into a portrait so when you
launch the app the phone turns the
correct way you can set display to stand
alone which hides the URL bar and makes
it look more like a nap appy experience
you can set a theme color background
color this display stand alone thing is
kind of interesting this is a video of
adding flipkart like to an android home
screen menu add to homescreen add if you
go home you can see the icon pops up the
name and icon are taken from the
manifest it looks just like a native app
when you tap it you get a launch screen
just like a native app and there's no
browser Chrome there's no URL bar no
back forward button if you weren't a
developer if you hadn't seen that
initial step you would have no idea that
this wasn't a native application in fact
a very well could have been I in the
same exact technologies you could be
using corto
or something and have built this already
as a native app it's just now you can
get there from the web instead of
proprietary paths but that's also kind
of weird because there's no URL bar and
the web is the web and how do you get
back to it the manifest spec is I think
the weakest of this trio of service
workers push and manifests because we
don't know how to surface it we don't
know how to tell users it like hey this
app those website wants to act like an
app it wants to be on your home screen
it's capable of doing that it knows how
to work offline and once you're in there
we don't really know how to say actually
if you want to send somebody link here's
how you get the URL we've experiment
with long pressing but that conflicts
with other things opera has recently
experimented with a rather interesting
option so where you swipe down and then
to the side and that pops from the app
experience into the browser experience
and then to get back they have this
little mobile phone badge by the URL bar
and soul I don't know clearly there's a
need for this sort of stuff there's a
need to be able to say here's my site's
name here's where it starts it really
only works in portrait mode though if
you're doing that you're maybe haven't
learned the lesson that the web can show
up on a fridge but I don't know about
this whole display stand alone thing
because is the web without URLs still
the web at all if you can't cut and
paste if you can't edit a URL like what
what is that so I don't know but we need
the rest of the metadata and we'll
figure it out this is somewhere that you
as developers by adopting this by
experiment with this can actually
provide a lot of meaningful input and
shape the direction of the web in the
the links on the slides repo and github
there's a link to the Firefox bug we've
just now started preparing to implement
display stand alone in Firefox for
Android there are a lot of open
questions you can come in you can
actually say well I've been thinking
about this of experiment with this this
doesn't work well this does work well so
it's something that we have to we have
to learn how to get there together
something that that's been very humbling
as a as a browser manufacturers we're
finally starting to realize that we
don't know how
to build websites we know how to build
web browsers but like those are big C++
code bases that are compiled and shipped
over the wire every couple of weeks or
every couple days for for hot patches
that don't resemble the web at all we've
had experiments like app cache that
totally failed app cache work great if
you were used it exactly how we wanted
you to use it to make the web work
offline but if you want to do something
fancy like that patching the response in
flight or if you want to say I want
specifically these things cached as a
fallback not as the primary resource we
didn't have have the tools for that so
the the browser manufacturers have
started trying to say all right let's
give the developers let's give you all
in this room and a set of tools a tool
box instead of a specific tool will give
you a tool box and we'll see what you do
and we'll try to learn from that it's
the same way that jQuery influenced the
document query selector method there was
a time when jquery and prototype and
moved to mootools and all these other
libraries competed on how fast they
could parse CSS selectors to find Dom
nodes because before those libraries the
way you selected Dom nodes was using an
xml query language called xpath because
browser manufacturers don't know how to
make websites but we can learn and when
we see these emergent properties and we
see people build things that make sense
then we can codify it so that's kind of
where we're starting with service
workers here's a bunch of tools or
toolbox we'll see what tools come out of
that the important things that we try to
work with the web I've seen people light
up at the suggestion they can hide the
URL bar like oh that's wonderful i can
finally disguise the fact that i'm using
the web I don't have to be a shame that
i'm using the web anymore and i think
that's that's not going to work
long-term the web has a lot of a lot of
quirks but when we work with them we get
to a better place so think about these
tools those things that you can use to
enhance your experience not replace the
web's experience i'm going to be around
all all day all day tomorrow please come
ask me more questions like I said the
the slides are online i tweeted the link
we also have two other m'zullians here
sitting in the back floki and ender who
will be doing a free workshop on these
technologies on monday
meetup.com / javascript iceland the
registration will open tomorrow just
after noon and kudos to these folks who
shared photos of the fridge in the pizza
so thank you so much I have stickers up
front and keep rockin the free web